me
常に眠い時期だよねこんにちははじめ所長ですねあのエアぽっつ持ってる方多いと思う
んですけどもその知り酒のエアポ2 pro ってあるんですよ僕は予約して何とか
買えたんですけどもめちゃくちゃ人気なんですよそもそもエアポーツっていうのは
bluetooth 機能を使って iphone どのパソコンの音で港湾やですね
聞く奴なんですけどもまぁ中にはこんな感じですね
パップ必要なんですけども
これすごいんですよめちゃくちゃ売れてて今も普通に手に入らなくなってて
amazon などで予約した予約なんか未来に帰るみたいなもう売れすぎてて今体に
入れないかで大人気でもの後で予約したんですけどもと土方に1か月ぐらいかかりまし
た何でこんな奴潰れてるかと言いますとローリングキャンセリング機能がめちゃくちゃ
凄いんですよ
はいやばいあやばいやばいやばい
あっこのへなく多いますをついてですけど何にも音が聞こえなくなりました外部の音を
一切遮断して音楽できる状態等ほど外部を取り込みモードっていう音楽とか消えてる
ように外部の音をちょっと取り込めで人とお話ししながら音楽ヒールって二つのモード
からですよ
それが売れれば要するに音楽に集中したい
て誰かと話しながらなんかなんか音楽聴きたいとき両方使い分けるっていうスーパー
シーズウェアポッツプロ
すぐそんなエアポーツプロなんですけどもなんと当該そんな貴重たちのものを二つ準備
しましたこれが何をしようかと言いますとそこ咲く桜起用が聞いてノイズキャンセルし
てるとマジで周りの音が全く聞こえないんですよ
よこれは摂津
はいというですね今回も一般アースの方に来ていただきました一般的な聴力を持って
いる男性の方なので x がどうしちゃってという話進めすごく一般なって両方エア
ぽつプロで火つける人会話してみます
んですかねっ
通す管を通す管でえっ
どういったん
女困難開く酒てないんですよだけないですよね
てみてふざけてないですよね
ふざけてないんですよね何するか本当は避けてないですよねー
やっていけない本当に聞こえないんでこれ僕もつけるとまず会話できないんじゃない
かって思ってちょっと1回したい者っていうと思います
ああいう尾崎理由ませんえっ
僕の喋り方で聞こえてません
ごっつはもう喋ってくださいん
はい押せるさあね ok 行きたいね何か喋ってくださいはい
なんかお外喋ってください
僕もわざわざの米国に何か聞いてください
あああ
なんとなくなんとなくわかりました
なぜこなくっえっな何んとろーわーく
軍はわかるフォロワーわかる
はだけを
work mac マック
ピアノマック learn パパソコ
ええなぁもう真っ暗マンバッグマックマッハバックへ
aa 等
map
mac マックが真っ黒下手アーマーくらいマークが食べたい
何か食べたいマック食べたい入っていてください
a あ
シコるくるマネーどれドライブスルー
シコるドライブスルーか涙大回転のライブドライブ
花びら大回転でシコる
個室雷鳥何時に起きましたか
影響何時に起きましたが今日なざっとしましたか
早 no
してない a せないしてるんですよ奥瀬ナイスてないですをしてない
エア合致しました今日逆にあー今聞いたダイターン
誤算はあっ僕あ今日は9時9時に起きました
か99階ガッツしたった90歳
hey
は割と普通の時間に起きてますよ
入って来ないための今まったく会話が通じないんですよなんで言ってました
何時に起きましたパワーカッツしました
レアしてラインタイプ事ですから仲介しただけだったら驚きましたよ僕はラーメンえび
屋さんで助けないと
何言った僕の認識はん
これぐらいですでやポスプロのノイズキャンセリングけどやばいんですよ音楽指摘恋の
すごい空間が出来上がってるね俺をつくってイヤホン
若干ゲームをやってみたらどんなのかやってみようと思いますや音楽ゲームじゃない山
の山っていうか阿部なきゃですよねああこれは床はなんか
もっともと耳栓ついてるようなもんなんだよいや女なんてやるか安全なんじゃないかと
か思っ
ております来世でついれますねじゃあイオンがやんだよゲルガー
はいいや壱番屋ですね
ポケットモンスター
ポケットモンスターポケットモンスター
村燃やした
ぽ検討モンスター
むらいのポスターへのポケットモンスター
ムラッとしましたわけごぞ
日本倒木は9時に起きました
あのー僕は人を殺しましたもう1回いけますよと
今日僕は僕は二時に起きました人を殺しました
今日は良いハイ曲は今日も来まーたを殺しました
ブーブー僕はうわーヌーは今日もか army フォローしました
[音楽]
ブーブー多くわーっ悪そう
ない
内のないじゃない
実は僕昨日チキン帝王バーガーのセットを頼みんが負担
ふっ昨日僕は耳金平をバーガーの絶倒
頼みました
[音楽]
チキン
全然チキン全然ブルー出勤昨日今日は僕は
チキンフィレよまあだった o 0
雪庇きゅんせ j ビデオバーカーローンってロぺロ
頼みましたと頼みましたとみました
鍛冶じゃああー
大番組でやるいや災害はギャル祝うるって a まずで何でもわからなかったほどやっ
てしまうよ
第一番目だぜた花いちもんめが入っポケットモンスター
ムラッと死亡したあったけど同じ問目は2本目が今日僕は9時に起きました
ています
今日僕が国に滅ぼしましたと言ってペルクラでもシラーのまた出荷に誰も目は3問目が
機能を僕は非農家昨日僕は禁忌猟バーガーのセットを頼みました
問題が入ってますか漁協が散っましたよ
あっ流行ってだねぇ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ